LAUREN STOVALL: |
always wanted a dog
that I could have off leash.
He sticks with me on
hikes, if I tell him to.
My name is Lauren Stovall.
I an a Bluegrass musician.
[MUSIC PLAYING] Spreads
her wings to fly.
LAUREN STOVALL: I first
got inspired by tiny living
a couple years ago.
There's a lot of
great hiking up here.
That's one of the things that
appealed to me about Boulder.
You have the town, and then,
literally, from downtown you
can walk to these
pretty epic trails.
Living up here, about 25
minutes from downtown,
there's that much more space.
Skippy is my full time roommate,
my best friend, my little dog.
He's a Jack Russell.
He's a little under 20
pounds, depending on the day,
and how many treats he's eaten.
He's 9 years old now, and I
got him when he was almost 2,
and I had developed a
pretty strong fascination
with Jack Russells.
It just so happened
that a friend of mine
had a Jack Russell
that she couldn't keep.
She shipped him out to
Colorado, and I met him
in the parking lot of
the Cracker Barrel,
and I wasn't so sure if
it was going to work out,
and the next day I fell in love.
This tiny house is
really special to me.
My dad and I designed it.
He built it out in Mississippi.
And brought it to
Colorado for me,
and it's been something that
we've, kind of, worked on.
The process has been something
that we went through together.
And he had the skills
and the ability.
I've been ready to
minimize for a long time,
but living out of the suitcase
for the last year and a half,
with the band and
stuff, just makes
you realize that you really
don't need that much.
It's really important to
have a spot for everything,
and to have these, sort
of, multifunctional--
like I have a stool, that's,
you know-- it's my ottoman,
it's my kitchen, table,
chair, and it's also
where I put my clothes.
It was cool being able
to design my own house,
because I did have a
bunch of things in mind
that I wanted, not just space
saving ideas, but things that,
sort of, represented
me, from little details,
like, oh, I want a ceiling fan.
That's something that we
grew up with in the south.
Of course, plenty
of storage is great.
And I wanted a lot of sunlight.
Skippy being in a tiny
house is pretty cute.
I had the couch custom built
so that I could put my guitar,
and some other things under it.
And there was just
this little space where
Skippy's bed happen to fit.
And another thing that was
really hugely important to me
was having a way for Skippy
to get up into the loft,
without me having to carry
him up and down the ladder
each night.
We designed the stairs to
cater to Skippy's needs.
Actually, he can get up them,
and he can get down them.
I do carry him down, though.
It feels a little safer
to his paranoid mother.
When people think of me,
they think of Skippy.
He's just a huge part of
my life, every single day.
And he really is my best friend.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
INTERVIEWER: Be
sure to check out
another episode with former
pro snowboarder, Mike Basich,
in his off-the-grid tiny home.
So this is your dream.
MIKE BASICH: This is it.
INTERVIEWER: Since
you were a little boy,
you've been wanting to do this.
MIKE BASICH: This is
my dream in reality.
40 acres to do whatever I want.
It's really fun.